StStéphanie Grandmont et
MiMichel C. Auger.
BoBonne fin d'après-midi.
- - Bonjour.
- - Stéphanie, le passeport.
C'C'est comme si on est tellemet
inincrédule devant l'incapacitéu
gogouvernement à gérer le
papasseport. Êtes-vous de la vie
dede ceux qui auraient dû voir
vevenir les demandes des grands
nonoms?
- - Absolument. C'est clair
ququ'après deux ans de pandémiùu
leles gens sont restés cloués àa
mamaison et là on arrive au
prpremier été et on sait que les
gegens peuvent voyager ce n'est
papas un mystère, les demandes
avavaient baissé jusqu'à 20 % de
leleur niveau habituel pendant e
dédébut de la pandémie. On
s's'imagine bien que ça
rereviendrait à un niveau plus
nonormal. Il fallait se préparer
etet on ne l'a pas fait.
C'C'est quand même fascinant pae
quque le gouvernement fédéral et
totoujours en retard sur la bale
ququand il est question des
trtransports depuis le début dea
papandémie. De manière généralen
didirait que le gouvernement
a a de la difficulté à gérer la
prprestation de services à la
popopulation. Que l'on parle des
papasseports en ce moment, ou ds
dédélais vraiment très longs par
exexemple dans le traitement des
dodossiers d'immigration.
OuOù toutes sortes d'autres
exexemples. On dirait qu'ils ont
dede la difficulté à livrer.
C'C'est inadmissible de voir les
gegens ce moment qui attende
dadans leur tente pratiquement
enenfile pendant 36 heures,
dede voir la police qui doit
dédébarquer dans le bureau de
seservice Canada, on se croirait
dadans une république de banane.
JeJe me demande comment tout çaa
fifinir. Il manque des personnes
papartout mais honnêtement, il
fafaut faire quelque chose.
- - Les policiers ont été appel,
çaça s'est relativement bien
papassé, les gens restent calmes
etet on comprend qu'il y a des
plpleurs, il y a de la frustratn
esest-ce que politiquement il ya
unun danger?
- - Oui bien sûr qu'il y a un
enenjeu. S'ils ne sont pas
cacapables de réels services à a
popopulation, qu'est-ce qui lui
ararrive? D'autre part il ne fat
papas oublier qu'il y a beaucoup
dede gens qui disent que les ges
ététaient négligents et ont laié
leleur passeport être échus mais
pependant la pandémie plusieurs
bubureaux des passeports étaient
fefermés. Service Canada n'est
trtraité que le passeport
esessentiel. Les bureaux sont ts
ououvertement depuis le mois
dedernier. Tout ça était
prprévisible. On peut le voir
vevenir. Il y a un problème au
niniveau de la livraison des
seservices. C'est amusant parce
quque le gouvernement dans son
prpremier mandat avait fait une
séséance de cabinet complète sur
lele mot anglais la livraison ds
seservices que c'était ça qui
ététait très important et puis
cocouler gouvernement. C'est pas
mamal ça qui en train d'arriver.
- - Stéphanie, vous les disiez,a
s's'ajoute à d'autres choses.
C'C'est comme si sur l'inflation
ilil ne bougeait pas, ils ont de
lala difficulté à prendre des
dédécisions, ils sont plus
réréactifs. Est-ce que ça fait
paparti de la personnalité de ce
gogouvernement? Est-ce que Justn
TrTrudeau est conforté par son
alalliance avec le NPD il se dit
quque tout va bien aller pour ls
trtrois prochaines années? Qu'e-
cece qui se passe gouvernement?
- - Ça ressemble un peu à ça. On
didirait qu'ils sont déjà partis
enen vacances. Ils n'ont pas
bebesoin de passeport.
EnEn même temps sur le point
spspécifique de l'inflation, moi
pepersonnellement je ne pense ps
quque le gouvernement doit
sese mettre à prendre toutes
sosortes de mesures pour essayer
d'd'aider les ménages. Ça alors
pepeut être cruel à dire mais ds
unun cas comme celui-là la
memeilleure façon d'agir c'est e
nene rien faire. Parce que
évévidemment les banques centras
sosont en train d'essayer de
reresserrer les taux d'intérêt
popour faire en sorte combattent
l'l'inflation. Si le gouvernemet
ararrive et jette de l'huile sur
lele feu en donne encore plus
d'd'argent pour aider les ménag,
çaça va plutôt nuire. Je sais qe
ChChrystia Freeland s'est faite
rereprocher la semaine dernière
d'd'abandonner un discours qui
ététait plutôt tiède, mièvre, je
nene sais pas quel qualificatif
esest usé, c'est peut-être vrai
mamais maintenant il faut se
gagarder dans ce dossier éviter
d'd'en faire trop.
- - Vous êtes aussi Michel de
cecette école?
- - Oui, d'autre part le problèe
dudu discours de Mme Freeland
ététait comble l'havé annoncé
cocomme quelque chose de
signgnificatif. Quand elle est
ararrivée. Quand le global elle
fafait là une en disant que Frua
nene renonce rien, ce n'est pas
popour rien que le gouvernementu
QuQuébec a décidé d'envoyer des
chchèques de 500 $. Ce n'est pe-
êêtre pas la chose à faire
pependant une période d'inflati.
LeLe travail, serait-ce la banqe
CaCanada qui peut le faire en
grgrande partie. Mais il faut qe
lala banque Canada sans que le
gogouvernement ne lui est pas ds
leles roues trouve des situatios
popolitiques y en a pas.
- - Parlons du REM. Michel savat
cocombien d'années que vous parz
dudu REM?
- - Depuis le début.
- - Encore retardé d'une année,l
y y avait des tunnels où les
exexplosifs ont créé un retard.
EsEst-ce que ça va aboutir un
jojour?
- - Un jour ça va aboutir. Sauf
quque les explosifs qui datent u
tetemps de la première guerre
momondiale sont dans le tunnel u
MoMont-Royal savait presque deux
anans qu'on sait ça.
UnUn moment donné ils ont bon ds
lele explosif. D'autre part, le
prproblème actuellement c'est la
réréputation du constructeur qui
esest en cause. Le maître dame
c'c'est la caisse de dépôt. Quad
çaça a commencé, je me suis
c'c'étais la caisse de dépô et
CDCDPQ infra qui devait disait e
çaça allait prêt.
C'C'était une carte de visite pr
momontrer au monde entier qu'ona
fafait ça dans le temps et danse
bubudget. Mais maintenant ce
n'n'était plus. C'est un gros
morceau pour la filiale infra de
lala caisse de dépôt.
CÇa va rester. Vous savez, tout
lele REM est basé sur la
réréputation de la caisse. C'étt
nonotre bas de laine. On aime bn
lala caisse. Mais la réputatione
lala caisse après un gros coup.
C'C'est inévitable.
- - Est-ce que ça ne vient pas
dédémontrer que dans le projet e
trtransport comme ce n'est pas a
plplace pour les entreprises qui
fofont des profits?
- - J'ai un peu dans la même
scscène que Michel dans la mesue
ouoù la caisse vous avait fait
mimiroiter cette espèce de miral
dede dire nous on est du privé t
onon va être capable de faire un
prprojet dans le temps et dans e
prprojet. Regardez nos allées, l
n'n'y en aura pas de mauvaises
susurprises. Finalement, qu'este
ququ'on réalise? Il y a des
dédépassements de coûts de
plplusieurs millions, des retous
dede plusieurs années.
EnEn plus qu'on regarde ça,
vivisuellement, ce n'est pas trs
artitistique le résultat qu'on
vovoit. SiSi vous êtes allé fain
totour sur le pont Champlain, vs
avavez vu les caténaires, les fs
aéaériens font circuler
l'l'électricité, ça gâche
l'l'esthétique du pont qui est
ququand même plutôt joli.
EÉvidemment je ne vous parle pas
dede certains quartiers qui sont
dédéfigurés par le passage du RM
dede l'Ouest. On est loin de la
vivision qu'on nous avait
prprésentée sur plan au tout
dédébut. Tout ça va casser un pu
cecette idée là du miracle, un
enentrepreneur du privé va réusr
lului à faire ce que le public
n'n'était pas capable.
- - On parle du REM de l'Ouest
mamais il y a le REM délaisse,
vovous avez prolongé l'entrevuee
ChChantal Rouleau dans le devoir
cece matin. Elle a dit que ce ne
seserait pas un tramway, ni au
mémétro ce sera un très léger et
enen grande parti aérien. Il me
sesemble que ça posait problèmee
soson grand-père tererrien.
- - Deux choses l'une. Ou bien
MaMadame rouleau nous décrit à a
fifin à peu près ce qui était le
plplan initial. Elle n'a pas
cocompris ce qui s'est passé à
l'l'hôtel de vill quand elle a t
ququ'elle enlevait le projet à a
cacaisse et en quelles données à
l'l'ARN TM. Elle dit quelque che
ququi est l'inverse de son premr
miministre auquel cas ça mais le
prpremier dans l'embarras. Je ne
sasais pas lequel des 2000 quele
chchose marche pas.
- - Je dirais j'espère que le RM
dédélaisse on va réussir à le
coconcevoir de concert avec un
plplan urbanistique qui fait le
bobonheur de l'Est.
CeCe qu'on voit dans l'Ouest et
ququ'on est arrivé avec un REM,n
trtransport structurant et on a
dedes stations où les villes se
didisent: "ah non nous ici on
n'n'avait pas de densification."
CoComme un point d'éclair la
popopulation a dit où il REM mas
onon ne veut pas des constructis
dede notre cours.
IlIl faut que tout ça se fasse n
cocohésion Inside père. Si on
papasse des réseaux structurants
ilil faut aller avec une idée de
trtransportation urbaine.
-S-Stéphanie Grandmont et Mich